[Aplausos]
[Música]
la península de los balcanes es un lugar
con 12 países que tienen una única cosa
en común el odio que se tienen unos a
otros durante décadas la mayor parte de
estos países estaban unidos en una gran
federación que por entonces se llamaba
yugoslavia
el mismo fue electo bono de china
tenía un sistema socialista muy parecido
al de la unión soviética pero tras la
caída del comunismo el estado yugoslavo
se vino abajo y todas las regiones que
lo conformaban se separaron de la forma
más violenta que os podáis imaginar los
que tengáis más de 30 años recordaréis
las terribles guerras de los balcanes
[Música]
todo un escaparate de lo más oscuro de
la condición humana a pocos kilómetros
de distancia de italia o grecia mientras
en el resto de europa vivíamos con
relativa comodidad en esta región se
estaban matando de las peores formas
posibles
desde entonces los balcanes son una de
las zonas más pobres de europa algunos
lo llaman el triángulo de las bermudas
económico porque cuando alguien invierte
en esta región su dinero desaparece
misteriosamente
y viajar a un país como albania es como
viajar 50 años atrás en el tiempo otros
países como serbia están creciendo mucho
en los últimos años pero todavía están a
años luz de poder entrar en la unión
europea y grecia que sería algo así como
el alumno aventajado de la clase está en
bancarrota y con un desempleo del 21 por
ciento vamos que no parece precisamente
el mejor lugar para hacer negocios
verdad pues mis queridos amigos de
visual política china no piensa como
vosotros
china está poniendo miles de millones de
euros en inversiones tanto en grecia
como en otros países balcánicos para
crear una nueva ruta de la seda que vaya
desde el mediterráneo hasta el corazón
de la unión europea hablamos de casi 20
mil millones de dólares es decir el
coste de unos juegos olímpicos en una
región donde prácticamente nadie más
invierte china ha comprado un puerto y
está levantando nuevas líneas de
ferrocarril que conectarían los balcanes
con budapest y que podrían terminar
llegando hasta alemania
pero no sólo eso el gobierno chino está
allanando el camino para que puedan
llegar inversores privados
os imaginais fábricas chinas en las
afueras de belgrado centros logísticos
de aliexpress en atenas pues es muy
probable que esto sea una realidad mucho
antes de lo que nos pensamos para que os
hagáis una idea si lo miramos en
términos relativos a su población china
está mostrando mucho más interés en
serbia o en grecia que en la mismísima
alemania
y os preguntaréis a qué se debe todo
este interés en los balcanes no se
supone que es una zona pobre corrupta y
con pésimas condiciones para la
inversión que quiere exactamente china
en los balcanes hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
un país de saldo en el año 2010 grecia
comienza con sus programas de ajuste de
presupuesto el país entero estaba en
bancarrota y la unión europea aceptó
rescatarlo con el dinero de los países
más ricos de europa a cambio de que el
gobierno sea apretar el cinturón
[Música]
desde entonces grecia ha estado inmersa
en toda clase de crisis políticas y
económicas el desempleo se ha situado
por encima del 20% y la pobreza no ha
dejado de crecer para que os hagáis una
idea grecia tiene una deuda que es casi
dos veces su producto interior bruto a
esto hay que sumarle que
tradicionalmente ha sido un país
alérgico a los negocios corrupción
burocracia y toda clase de restricciones
que hacen que apenas haya empresas
importantes en este país
desde bruselas exigían que el gobierno
de alexis tsipras hiciera reformas
políticas y vendiera algunas de sus
empresas públicas para hacer frente a la
enorme deuda que tienen el problema pues
que con semejante panorama a las
propiedades del gobierno griego se
tuvieron que sacar a precio de saldo de
otro modo nadie estaba dispuesto a
comprar en otras palabras que grecia
estaba y todavía está en una situación
desesperada y si hay alguien que puede
oler la desesperación desde kilómetros
de distancia esa es china
[Música]
la empresa china cosco adquiere el 51%
de la propiedad del puerto griego de el
pireo
con esta operación china mataba dos
pájaros de un tiro' por un lado una de
sus empresas se hacía con uno de los
principales puertos del mediterráneo y
por el otro xi jinping se comprometía a
invertir otros tres mil millones de
dólares en el país para ganarse un
aliado político en la unión europea que
sí que ella se lo que estoy pensando el
presidente de grecia
alexis tsipras estaba una rockstar de la
izquierda europea verdad un hombre que
jamás vendería sus ideas y sus valores a
un malvado capitalista por mucho dinero
que ponga sobre la mesa verdad pues lo
cierto es que no
grecia bloquea las críticas de la unión
europea a las violaciones de derechos
humanos de china grecia ha vetado una
condena de la unión europea en la onu
enfureciendo los diplomáticos y las
organizaciones humanitarias que dicen
que este movimiento socava la posición
de la unión europea al defender los
derechos humanos pero esperad un momento
porque no sólo de política vive el
hombre vamos a mirarlo desde el punto de
vista económico ahora las empresas
chinas controlan uno de los puertos más
grandes de europa
eso significa que china tiene ahora más
facilidad que nunca para descargar sus
containers con sus mercancías en uno de
los mercados más ricos del planeta
europa
[Música]
pero hay un pequeño problema desde el
puerto del pireo hasta berlín hay más de
2.300 kilómetros y por el camino solo
atravesamos países relativamente pobres
con malas carreteras y ferrocarriles
cochambrosos pero tranquilos porque
también china ha pensado en esto os
acordáis de este vídeo en el que os
hablábamos de la nueva ruta de la seda
el llamado proyecto one belt one road
que quiere construir xi jinping se trata
de una red de infraestructuras que
conectarían el mundo entero y en europa
esa ruta pasa directamente por los
balcanes
comienza la construcción del ferrocarril
belgrado budapest a la vez varias
consultoras chinas están trabajando para
renovar las rutas de ferrocarril entre
grecia y macedonia la idea es que en un
futuro un cargamento que desembarque en
el pireo pueda atravesar toda la
península balcánica a una velocidad de
160 kilómetros por hora y todo ello por
un precio mucho más barato que si las
líneas de ferrocarril se construyeran
vamos a decir en italia por ejemplo
pensadlo bien en los balcanes el terreno
y la mano de obra es más barata que en
ninguna parte de europa y los gobiernos
están recibiendo esa inversión con los
brazos abiertos como decíamos al
principio los balcanes todavía no se han
terminado de recuperar tras las guerras
de los años 90 para que os hagáis una
idea en una ciudad como belgrado todavía
se pueden ver edificios derruidos por
los bombardeos de la otan del año 1999 y
un país como montenegro ni siquiera
tiene ferrocarril que le conecte con
bosnia o croacia y todo esto a pesar de
que son países vecinos
[Música]
y no olvidéis que es algo grave y
croacia ninguno de estos estados
pertenece a la unión europea eso
significa que apenas reciben dinero de
bruselas para reconstruirse así que
todos esos préstamos que están haciendo
los chinos vienen como maná caído del
cielo
[Música]
cuando hablamos de esto con los países
europeos nos preguntan por qué china
pues para ser honestos porque son los
que tienen el dinero pero esperad un
momento porque aquí no termina la
historia y si china estuviera dispuesta
a ir un poquito más lejos
[Música]
factorías chinas y en europa todos lo
sabemos china comenzó a crecer gracias a
las empresas extranjeras que se
instalaban en las zonas económicas
especiales por cierto que si queréis
conocer esta historia más a fondo la
explicamos en este otro vídeo pero lo
cierto es que el principal atractivo que
ofrecía china en los años 90 era seamos
honestos salarios bajos sin embargo las
cosas ya no son lo que eran fijaos en
esta gráfica
hoy en día el sueldo medio en una ciudad
como shanghai es casi el mismo que el
que se cobra en grecia y más del doble
de lo que se cobra en serbia es decir
que para una empresa china
belgrado sería algo parecido a lo que en
su día podía ser shenzhen para un
estadounidense a esto hay que sumarle
que la educación en un país como serbia
es razonablemente buena y está a tiro de
piedra de alemania
en otras palabras que tenemos mano de
obra barata bien educada y cercana a uno
de los mercados más atractivos del
planeta vamos que es como el paraíso
para hacer cosas como esta
la empresa china hebei firmó un acuerdo
para comprar una planta de acero serbia
por supuesto que la noticia es del año
2016 y todavía no hay muchos más
ejemplos para mostrar pero si son casos
suficientes como para mostrar una
tendencia las empresas chinas quieren
fabricar cosas en europa y los balcanes
son la zona perfecta más concrétamente
serbia
y eso explica que ese mismo año 2016 el
mismísimo xi jinping hiciera una visita
oficial a belgrado o que huawei haya
invertido una barbaridad para mejorar
las telecomunicaciones del país el año
pasado en 2017 el banco de china abría
sus primeras sucursales serbias vamos
que las relaciones entre estos dos
países no podían ir mejor
pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando
siempre os decimos aquí en visual
político que la corrupción no se lleva
muy bien con la inversión extranjera y
en lo que a corrupción se refiere serbia
no parece el lugar más transparente del
planeta pero por si algo se caracterizan
los empresarios chinos es por moverse
como pez en el agua en los entornos más
hostiles ya lo han demostrado con todas
las fábricas textiles que han montado en
países como etiopía y seamos honestos su
propio país china tampoco es
precisamente un oasis de seguridad
jurídica y democracia que digamos
mientras tanto a medida que la inversión
llega a los balcanes el europeísmo en
esta zona está en horas bajas para que
os hagáis una idea en el año 2012 el 70%
de los serbios quería entrar en la unión
europea
e incluso algunos se planteaban cambiar
el alfabeto por si no lo sabíais el
serbio es una lengua eslava y se escribe
en alfabeto cirílico pues bien muchos
intelectuales proponían cambiarse al
alfabeto latino como ya se hizo por
ejemplo en croacia pues bien ese fervor
europeísta ha bajado al 35 por ciento a
fin de cuentas teniendo dinero chino
quien necesita esos fondos de cohesión
de bruselas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en las pasadas elecciones presidenciales
ninguno de los principales candidatos a
presidente del país hablaba de entrar en
la unión europea sin embargo no parece
que nada de esto preocupe demasiado en
bruselas como os decía hasta el momento
solamente china ha sido capaz de ver
oportunidades de negocio en esta zona
del mundo para el resto de los mortales
los balcanes son un desierto tanto
político como económico algo parecido
ocurrió con muchas zonas de áfrica donde
nadie se atrevía a invertir de repente
llegó el dinero de pekín y hoy en día
están creciendo como si no existiera
mañana así que la pregunta es veremos un
despertar en los balcanes tal y como
está ocurriendo en otras zonas de áfrica
podría convertirse grecia o serbia y
bosnia herzegovina en un nuevo centro
industrial para los mercados europeos
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios mientras tanto si queréis
saber más sobre las inversiones brutales
que china está cometiendo en áfrica
hacer clic en este otro vídeo y como
siempre no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribimos a visual polític para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]